calcium is the third element in group
two on the periodic table it's really
very common we find it all over the
world in all sorts of minerals
so for example you can have bones this
is a pelvis of a sheep I found it when I
was walking one day you can see the legs
go in there and there okay so here we
have some calcium turnings okay so and
we're storing them in our glove box so
this glove box here is a contraption
full of nitrogen okay it's dry nitrogen
so that we can keep our calcium away
from oxygen and away from moisture as
well because obviously what we don't
want is let me get our nice very active
calcium surface we don't want it to to
tarnish from oxides you know too quickly
before week before we can react it with
things so what we have here inside the
bottle our turnings of calcium calcium
is quite hard compared to some of the
heavier group two elements so strontium
and barium and so it's harder to kind of
file bones are made from calcium
phosphate mixed with some organic
material as well and they're very strong
because of the structure within the
bones there are all sorts of shells of
mollusks and the like where they use
calcium carbonate from the seawater
getting the calcium out reacting with
carbon dioxide and making their shells
and because shells are made out of
calcium carbonate which dissolves in
acid people are quite worried about the
effects of global warming not the
heating up but when the co2 dissolves
into the sea it makes it more acid
so in principle shells could start
dissolving and some mollusks may not be
able to survive because they just can't
make their shells we just pour them out
so you can see calcium looks metallic
them the calcium metal itself because of
the way the electrons behave in the
solid in fact it's because it's a very
good electrical
actor but the compounds are all white
because calcium has no free electrons
that can go from one energy level to
another in the way that you can say in
copper so copper sulfate is a beautiful
blue color calcium sulfate is white and
it's actually colorless so if you see
big crystal of calcium sulfate just
looks like glass but the white is caused
by very small crystals which scatter the
light just in the same way that any sort
of white powder will scatter light
flower for example or talcum powder
anything like that and calcium compounds
themselves are actually mostly white
actually
but calcium metal itself as usually got
tarnished parts but also there are some
shiny bits okay where it's an tarnished
you actually see in the metal the luster
of the metal there as well calcium
carbonate dissolves in water saturated
with co2 to make calcium bicarbonate
which is more soluble and so you can get
water so called hard water that has
quite high levels of calcium and when
this percolates through the ground and
comes to a cave it can then crystallize
out and you can get hanging down pillars
of calcium carbonate which are called
stalactites and you can have pillars
growing from the floor called
stalagmites this is a Stalag Mike from
Turkey one of my friends called Hugh was
really naughty he knew I was interested
in minerals and he broke this off from a
cave in Turkey about 45 years ago and
brought it and gave it to me so I was
really pleased and you can see the
outside looks quite blobby and inside
you can see there are nice crystals of
calcium carbonate because it has grown
very very slowly and so it can
crystallize
and sometimes these stalagmites and
stalactites can grow really big and more
recently in the last few years people
have found huge crystals of calcium
sulfate under the ground some of you may
have seen pictures of caves in Mexico
where their crystals that big enough
that you can actually walk along them so
there's no danger that calcium will ever
run out is the basis of cements and
concrete or one of the bases because
then you need other elements like iron
and silica to make the concrete itself
but calcium is one of the principal
components we're going to take calcium
chloride put it in a flame and do a
flame test and see if we can see the
color of the calcium in the flame
so as I said before about calcium
compounds calcium compounds are often
white and here's a white calcium
compound
so I'm going to put in the flame and see
if we get any color
oh hello
I was quite read doesn't it okay so
brick-red
is the classic calcium color
5-bit orangie to me might be a bit of
sodium in there was
that was a
calcium test the reason that you don't
find lumps of calcium metal lying around
the way that you do with copper or gold
is that metallic calcium is very
reactive reacts with water very quickly
magnesium doesn't react because it has a
layer of oxide on the surface so
surprisingly magnesium is not nearly as
reactive as calcium you can use
magnesium or it's alloys for the wheels
on your car go around really fast
because they liked you couldn't have
calcium wheels in your car well you
could but the first time it rains your
whole car would go up in flames again
what we've got is our calcium chloride
hydrated calcium chloride we've got a
bunch of it on this spatula I'll put it
in the flame so you can see that it's
burning with a brick red flame which is
characteristic of calcium
it's kind of a little bit orangie to me
as well actually
might be a bit so Dimas here
any more on them
many people see calcium as a very
English element unlike strontium which
was discovered in Scotland because of
the White Cliffs of Dover the gateway
for many people when they first come to
England the made of calcium carbonate
and so this white color of chalk is very
characteristic and all over the southern
part of England use find large amounts
of chalk which in the north of England
they tend to be limestone which is also
calcium carbonate but it's a slightly
different variety of calcium carbonate
so it's a yellow or honey color because
of the impurities of iron or some other
element that's in it well you need
calcium for all sorts of processes in
the body and of course to build up your
bones particularly is say in the case of
pregnant women they need to have calcium
for the bones of the developing baby but
as people get older the calcium can come
out of their bones make them very
fragile this is why elderly people
sometimes break their hips oh and break
their bones so easily so drinking milk
and other sources of calcium sources of
calcium are good because it helps you
replenish your bones and keep a
reasonable level of calcium